this video is sponsored by super prism
games illusion connect is a mobile
tactical shoujo rpg for the ios
and android taking place in the world of
dream where monsters called nightmares
are born and are trying to destroy
all of humanity and you have to command
a group of radiants to fight them and
protect
us all right look i'mma be real with you
though you know the real reason i'm here
you know the deal i know the deal i love
my 2d anime girls and just
look at all these beautiful waifus man
there are over 60 characters available
with a wider range of personalities and
designs and just look at these thighs
man
if signs could create the perfect thighs
these would be
it this man this is art
you have the option to pick your
favorite girl to be on your home screen
and um
you know the deal the game uses a
real-time battle system where you have
to strategically drop your radiance in
specific blocks using a range of team
comps and strategies to defeat the enemy
and it also has a base building function
where you can build the perfect home for
your perfect
2d girl if you want to give it a go
click the link in the description today
to download this on ios and android
where you can get a free tempo
and you can also use promo code ic
giggup for extra rewards
and with that said let's get on with the
video remember how last season was like
i mean
well this season is
bam what the hell is going on there are
38 new [ __ ] shows airing the season
38. if you were to try and keep up with
everything that's almost like watching
three seasons of anime every week we
definitely have more choice this time
and we're gonna need it this is gonna be
the last season of anime before 2020 is
up so it's the last
chance to leave a mark on this year what
is going to be remembered what is going
to be forgotten how are we going to sum
up
the year of 2020
[Music]
yeah that pretty much sums it up
the original cute girls do psychopathic
things has returned with one of the most
famous horror franchises in anime and
i gotta be honest i'm not a very big fan
of horror especially when it comes to
anime due to it very rarely being able
to well
scare me and because of this i never
really gave the original higarashi a
proper shot
watching it dubbed where it's almost
impossible to take seriously when the
protagonist sounds like [ __ ] sonic
the hedgehog
like i said i'll discuss the details
when you get here but you know what i'm
really liking what i see so far it's not
just about the gruesome murder scenes
but seeing the mystery of this town
unfold in front of you the characters
can be genuinely unnerving and it's way
more effective than using some [ __ ]
jump scare to get a shock out of me
with the amount of shows airing the
season i was like i'm not even gonna
attempt to cover any of the sequels
here they are they exist but now has
been confirmed that this is an original
story which gets
all the more confusing when we factor in
the time looping plot [ __ ] so i
don't know if this is going to be a
remake
sequel reboots retelling ultimate
timeline [ __ ]
supper percent glitchless speed run new
game plus higarashi 2.0 plus one you
cannot
i don't care about any of that the real
question is is this going to be an
endless bait
or endless great also watching this i
can't help but feel just a little bit
nostalgic
because i remember back in the day when
we all thought higarashi no nakakorani
was this long-winded name and all made
jokes about it
and now we have names like himitobokuno
saigon osenjo aruiwa sakaiga hajimaru
seisen and be like well
that was just an adequately titled like
novel name so yeah this is kind of just
anime romeo and juliet with a
sorry this is just bothering me a bit
let me just okay
or better now so like i was saying yeah
this is just anime romeo and juliet with
that
sorry sorry again can i just all right
let's try this again this is just anime
romeo and juliet okay
has no one in the show heard of a
[ __ ] hairbrush
all right this is anime romeo and joe
for [ __ ] sake moving on
why are you gay you know sometimes you
need a jacked up shown an action show
sometimes you need a generic isekai to
fry your brain and sometimes you just
need to see some cute anime girls be
really cute and really really gay
who says i'm gay you are gay i like this
one it's probably the most promising
yuri anime i've seen since blooming to
you there's not much more that needs to
be said
it's cute it's gay it's comfy i love it
if you like yourself some wholesome yuri
i can't think of any reason you
shouldn't watch this
thai review
[Music]
foreign
you know i'm getting a bit worried that
the amount of good things that seems to
be happening to anime protagonists right
after they get hit by trucks i mean
getting easy card is one thing but now
you can find your perfect wife too
look i get what you're trying to do
anime but this ain't gonna convince
weebs to get married
it's gonna convince them to hold
themselves in front of a moving [ __ ]
vehicle honestly though the show is cute
as [ __ ] and exactly what you need to
cleanse yourself with a wholesome
rom-com because you know nothing quite
screams innocent anime couple more than
having a literal husband and wife pair
who are still
frothing at the thought of holding hands
you know i'm dreading the day when anime
characters discover there's more lunar
things you can do
than some uncensored first name calling
you remember early in the year when a
certain anime youtuber hyped up the idea
that webtoon's adaptations could usher
in a new era of high-profile
international anime adaptations
me neither following on from the
interesting world of tower of god and
the visually spectacular
but disappointing and rushed adaptation
that was god of mid school
we have nablis which is doing a
fantastic job at being completely
indisputably unremarkable you know i
really did have high high hopes at the
beginning but the quality of webtoons
adaptation seems to be progressing in
the opposite direction of what i want so
far
all right this is moving too slow time
for some quick fire ones we got kino's
journey
which edition moriarty's got his own
anime this time getting back at the rich
in yeah the
england british people be like hey
anyone got a sega
douga cobra are back with some more
fluff porn this one's cute i like this
one
it's just the struggles of a moe
princess he'll do anything just to get a
good night's sleep
i hate that my life's gotten to the
point where i can relate to this on a
spiritual level
hell yeah boys we got ourselves another
baseball anime to get hyped over baby
oh wait it's just another june show yes
jin maeda is back to torture our hearts
with another pa works original anime
this time we have a small anime girl who
appears one day and just straight up
claims
i'm a god okay while she initially seems
like a loud annoying lottie with a few
screws loose it quickly becomes clear
that she does have some kind of power
she predicts event after event after
event and just as we realized that maybe
she is what she says she is she reveals
that the world is actually going to end
in 30 days
say what you want about jinmayer and his
works but there's always a certain charm
to it which is definitely present here
the characters and dynamics were just a
delight to watch and there were even
some scenes that got a genuine laugh out
of me but
you know i've seen charlotte i've seen
angel beats i've seen like eight
episodes of clan ads i know how this
works now no matter how light-hearted
and fun it is at the beginning i know
it's only a matter of time before this
show tries to destroy me and my soul
and i can already tell it definitely has
the potential to do that i just hope he
has an adequate
episode count this time and i don't end
up crying a yet another rushed ending
oh gosh
okay like i know this is meant to be a
sad moment and everything but
can we just appreciate that the grandpa
literally just went the guess i'll die
route with the prestige and track record
that comes with the brand whenever a
fresh new shonen jump title gets adapted
into an anime there always seems like
there's this extra layer of hype
surrounding it
will this be good will this be popular
will this be in the next big three
or the next big five or the next big
seven or the next big one
and from first impressions jiu jitsu
kaisen
definitely has a shot at that one thing
i've learned that shonen jump titles
don't really have to do anything
different from the established formula
as long as it does it well and this
seems to be a match up with the best
parts of bleach yuihaku show demon
slayer
nah how about demon finger 100 norigami
slayer there's even upside down face
kakashi but through all this it still
manages to carve out its own corner
coming from the same studio and director
as god of high school
the one great thing that seems to have
carried over is the fantastic action
direction not to mention it's got one of
the most stylistically awesome endings
i've seen all year but by far the thing
that's got me the most hyped out of
anything is this one shot of a panda
running on a roof
it's a [ __ ] panda doing parkour on a
roof
why is this here i have so many
questions
anyway moving on
i love refrigerators if i had to pick a
dark horse that people might be sleeping
on the season
this show would be it akadama drive is
essentially suicide squad 2077 directed
by guy richie it's a cyberpunk
action-packed extravaganza following a
group of stupidly over-the-top criminals
as they team up to pull off the biggest
heist in history you've got a
psychopathic serial killer a
psychopathic doctor a psychopathic
brawler a psychopathic hacker you've got
a guy spider-man a [ __ ] motorbike
across the cyberpunk
city and also there's like a talking cat
or something i don't [ __ ] know it's a
series oozing with style and attitude it
walks that line of overloading your
visual senses without
stepping too far into the world of
gohan's handshakers bullshittery and is
way
better than what i expect from studio
periods this is looking like it's gonna
be pure balls to the walls fun and i
am here for it what the [ __ ] why is
youtube recommending me climbing videos
i've never been interested in climbing
my entire life
hey guys it's your boy gig uk
freeclimbing69 like i was saying i'm a
massive fan of climbing been doing it
for years love watching everything
climbing related highly recommend people
take up this hobby been waiting for this
anime ever since it was announced the
show's going to be a huge win for us
all in the armpit gang wait what oh isa
kylert
easy kyler you know at this point
watching the first episode of a new
isakai just feels like playing a damn
tutorial stage
i know it's extra jump left trigger to
aim light attack heavy attack an
anti-social nerd in a fancy world
surrounded by cute anime girls i get it
i'm familiar with all the systems so i'm
just waiting for that unique hook that
is the slight differentiation from the
formula
so you see in this one guys people don't
die when they are killed
and that's something we've never seen
before you ever tried to describe a show
in layman's terms so your friend can
understand using pop culture references
and sometimes it's a bit of a
[ __ ] like oh yes like the
avengers mixed with my little pony if
they were playing monopoly set in the
witcher with a little bit of four guys
mixed in
well talentless nana is literally just
among us
hero academia no seriously this time
you've got a school full of kids with
superpowers in a world where such
individuals have caused massive
disasters so to get rid of them the
government need to covertly kill them
off without anyone
finding out enter nana who is secretly
powerless and not only has to pretend
she has the ability to read minds using
just her deduction and psychology
but also has to secretly assassinate the
kids one by one while they have full
knowledge that they could be a traitor
amongst the class who is an enemy to
them
yeah like i said it's so on point to a
game of superhero among us
it's almost like their release was
coincided like there's even a scene
we've all experienced before if you've
played a game that's just like hey pink
have you seen blue anywhere
no i haven't that's strange because
blue's been missing since 7pm last night
and nobody knows where he is
i'm his neighbor so i know he never
comes home past 9 p.m and i didn't hear
a single peep last night
therefore i can conclude that he never
in fact made it back home
and it's even more curious that for some
reason he went missing after he went off
with a certain someone
yes the last time he was seen leaving
his room was at 1900 hours with a
certain pink haired girl
a certain girl who matches your exact
description
so two people left but only one returns
which by any account
looks pretty damn sus so
what do you have to say for yourself
pink no you
[Music]
[ __ ]
guys hope you enjoyed that video thank
you again to illusionconnect for
sponsoring me today
if you want to try out the game and try
your hands at collecting some of their
top tier waifus
click the link in the description to
download their game today
and with that said thank you very much
to mike elfin
sisters10086 walter ivido
zeke098 and everyone else my patreon for
sponsoring me for this month and just a
quick note i know in the past two months
i've been uploading on this channel a
bit less than
what i would usually do i promise guys
i've not been lazy i've actually just
been putting some extra time into
workings on some bigger projects on my
other channel
trash taste but also i've taken a little
time to really try and think about what
direction i want to take this channel
and what kind of content i want to be
making
if you couldn't i've kind of been
experimenting with different kinds of
content
here and there and part of the challenge
is trying to figure out how i can
balance the workload so i don't [ __ ]
kill myself and work myself to death
don't worry i've not given up on my old
content or anime content in general
it's just taking a little time to figure
out what a new sustainable schedule
could be for myself so yeah that's just
a very brief update in what's been
happening on my end i don't even know if
anyone's noticed to be honest
so yeah don't worry i'm not going
anywhere i'm still grinding away and
i've got
plenty of ideas that i want to explore
on this channel so until then
i've been gigguk and i'll see you all
next time